public servants working from home early
in the show well seemingly nothing can
lure them back to their offices i think
i may have found out why
it's the barely fathomable revelation
the staff from the department for work
yes work and pensions have been offered
feel-good seminars on smut the 45-minute
course entitled the history of sex toys
is described as a titillating time warp
through ancient greece via the
victorians up to the modern day well
that's just great isn't it that's going
to sort out wade stagnation and the
inflation crisis and soaring food prices
more than two years into a pandemic and
73 percent of the staff of department of
work and pensions are still at home
i can't imagine why can you
prime minister may have been hoping for
just before the election of the weekend
now uh scott morrison who calls himself
the bulldozer lived up to his name he
broke off from campaigning in tasmania
to gatecrash a boys football game at
devonport striker soccer club this is
what happened
[Applause]
[Music]
i've actually got a bit of sympathy for
the aussie pm i've got three sons and
whenever i play football then that was
normally what used to happen at some
stage the challenge when you reach a
certain age and physical stature is that
when you start to tumble there's simply
no stopping you and if it does happen to
be a useful small object in the vicinity
they can be quite a useful buffer uh
morris is not the first political leader
to discover this you can forget of
course boris johnson's own battle with
gravity and children back in 2015.
well boyce johnson was merely the mayor
of london back then so he didn't do his
political career any harm so maybe this
will swing things the bulldozer's way in
the australian election
i think you may agree that this might be
insanity a woman in america was charged
forty dollars by her doctor for crying
yeah you heard me right a viral tweet
posted by the patient's concern sister
showed her medical bill her concern
twister tweeted the incident saying yep
there it is listed as a brief emotional
behavior assessment it's called crying
because she had a rare condition that
felt understandably sad about it i guess
you're lucky you didn't charge her for
breathing the world is going nuts but
we're here to put it right well
generations of children in the scouts
and girl guides have been honored with
badges for honing their life skills in
orienteering camping navigation yeah
real skills now they have a brand new
challenge
[Music]
yes the new challenge for british gold
guides for which they actually get
badges lording their success is walking
to the chip shop
the new badge features a smiling lady
french fry and hiking boots happily
straight into a chip shop while hungry
brandishing a fork kids can get another
badge for eating a pizza i'm not joking
all this is the uk is set to become the
fattest country in europe with 37
percent of the nation obese by 2030. the
official goal guiding twitter account
says it's absolutely worth teaching and
celebrating adding the recipients of
being honored in for their independence
enjoying the outdoors money management
and following directions following
directions really to a chip shop judging
by the fat record in this country we
have no problem finding chip shops
i love kilts
the national dress of bonnie scotland a
celebrated part of scottish culture for
almost 500 years
but not anymore obviously
the scottish government has issued
anti-racism guidance to schools warning
teachers they should be avoiding showing
scots and tilts
really
all the best people should wear them
as you can see
kids should dress in the clothes of
other cultures the government says to
make them global citizens the kilts are
a stereotype
really so the only culture these kids
are not allowed to appropriate is their
own well i'm sorry
i'm not having it because that's
ridiculous on this show we celebrate
scottish culture
so that's it from me and here
is some scottish music for the blog
[Music]
you